as of september 2021 apple has released
13 series of iphones with a total of 33
models including the iphone se 2nd
generation the only model in its lineup
to use a generation tag after its name
the story of the iphone is a classic
example of what a once in a generation
product can do to the prospects of a
tech company in fact apple is more than
just a tech company today it has become
more of a cultural force to reckon with
however just over a decade and a half
ago this was not true at all in this
video we will reminisce a bit about the
history of the iphone the people
involved in its enormous success and how
a simple concept forever changed the way
we interact with a phone when steve jobs
took the reins of apple for the second
time in 1997 the company was in deep
financial trouble its main product was
the macintosh performa an expensive
desktop computer launched in 1995
targeting a very niche customer segment
the company was a far cry from the
global tech giant it is today and
definitely far from being a smartphone
manufacturer under jobs leadership in
just over five years apple launched the
imac g3 in 1998 and the revolutionary
ipod in 2001. these two products would
establish apple as a household name in
the early 2000s but the best was yet to
come in january 2007 at a mac world
convention jobs announced the launch of
the iphone later that year in june the
first iphones began flying off the
shelves in apple showrooms across the
u.s steve jobs introduced the iphone
with the slogan apple reinvents the
phone and just like the ipod
revolutionized listening to music a few
years earlier phones would never be the
same again the first iphone or iphone 2g
as many would later call it was
comparable to other phones of that
generation in its technical
specifications it only had 16 gigabytes
of internal storage and a 2 megapixel
camera similar to other phones of its
time but the paradigm shift was in its
user interface it replaced the
traditional qwerty keyboards with a
touch interface that allowed multiple
inputs by using fingers us looking back
now it seems so obvious but in 2007
making a phone and an internet
communicator that totally eliminated
buttons of any kind was a bold decision
in fact it took a few years to even
convince steve jobs of the idea but once
he was convinced work on project purple
the code name of the iphone project
began in earnest and in complete secrecy
the iphone hardware team was led by tony
fidel the man who was then overseeing
the entire ipod lineup for apple he and
his team had already integrated a very
rudimentary form of internet browsing on
earlier ipod models and played around
with the idea of creating an ipod style
phone but steve jobs was not satisfied
with that concept the idea of a
multi-touch screen for the iphone came
from a different project with an apple
called the q79 tablet project which was
an experimental ipad light device those
early experiments gave the iphone
hardware team the confidence to push
forward they knew that the technology
existed to make a phone that would not
only make calls but also browse the
internet and play mp3s all without the
help of a single button it seems such a
bold decision could only be made at
apple under steve jobs because they had
always prioritized design over
engineering in almost all mobile phone
manufacturers those days new product
development began at the engineering
desk it would only pass on to the
designers once the engineers had ironed
out all the technical specifications and
created a working model this led to a
very clunky design language that can be
seen throughout the early smartphones of
the late 90s and 2000s the iphone design
team was led by jonathan ive the head of
industrial design at apple at the time
the british designer had his own private
team of 18. his office was so secretive
that only top apple execs were allowed
in since it contained all the sensitive
designs and prototypes of new apple
products the challenge in front of him
was to design a product that in reality
is incredibly complicated but needs to
be surprisingly intuitive to use his
team had already tasted success with the
imacs and the ipods both these products
inform the design language they chose
for the iphones its sleek form factor
was inspired by the lessons first
learned during the design of the imax
the world's first compact desktop
computer and the iphone's home button
was directly copied from the design of
the ipods where this form of navigation
control first gained appeal the final
bit of the iphone puzzle was designing
the right kind of software for this
ingenious design this responsibility
fell on scott forstall and his team of
user experience developers they were
given the job of developing a linear
scrolling interface optimized for touch
control letting the user interact with
the device in ways never before possible
to do this they decided to take the
existing mac os and shrink it to create
the very first version of ios a branch
of the mother operating system
specifically optimized for the iphone it
wasn't until the launch of the iphone 3
and 3s in 2008 and 9 respectively that
the significance of this feature was
fully realized even by the team that
developed it the new models launched
with the app store and changed things
very quickly it allowed third-party app
developers experienced on mac os to come
into the ios ecosystem and develop
various apps taking advantage of the
phone's 3g connectivity increased
storage and improved camera the app list
grew exponentially forstall's decision
to model ios on mac os soon proved to be
crucial for the worldwide success of the
iphones by the end of 2009 apple had
only sold over 34 million units of these
first iphone models but the world of
mobile apps led by the app store had
matured android os was soon launched and
the entire smartphone market started
making phones similar to the iphone and
creating their own app stores the next
two years saw major upgrades in the form
of the iphone 4 and 4s more storage and
processing power were required as apps
and media generated by iphone users
exploded so the internal storage and
memory were expanded to 64 gigabytes and
512 megabytes the cameras also received
a massive upgrade to a whopping 8
megapixels and introduced 1080p video
siri was introduced on iphone 4s as well
that opened up a whole new way of
interacting with the iphone by this time
the popularity of the iphone as a
cultural phenomenon was well established
this can be seen in their sales figures
in 2010 and 11 apple sold over 115
million units which were more than three
times the early three years combined but
2011 also saw a major change in apple's
management steve jobs left his role as
the ceo of the company due to his
deteriorating health and was replaced by
tim cook who still holds the role today
ever since jobs was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer cook had been
responsible for most of apple's
day-to-day operations and he had a major
role to play in reviving apple's
fortunes from the early 2000s in
partnership with jobs the first iphone
model launched by cook was the iphone 4s
after steve jobs death in october 2011.
however the models that had a
significant imprint of his leadership
were the iphone 5 series onwards after
becoming ceo cook rejigged the entire
management team at apple scott forstall
resigned as the head of ios the position
was filled by the current head craig
federighi jonathan i was handed the
leadership of apple's human interface
team and bob mansfield became the head
of hardware engineering through 2012 and
13 cook launched three iphone models 5
5s and 5c the phone's memory was doubled
to 1 gigabyte and lte connectivity was
added allowing internet access
everywhere these iphone models
introduced the lightning connector for
the first time replacing the old usb
style connector apple's proprietary m
series of motion co-processors was also
first introduced in the 5c model these
three iphone 5 models sold over 15
million units combined in their launch
weekend alone in 2015 the iphone team
made a huge leap from series 5 to iphone
series 6. the biggest difference was a
significantly larger screen offering an
even larger size called six plus the
retina display also became hd and the
option to get an iphone with 128
gigabytes of storage became available
for the first time later in 2016 the
iphone 6s and 6s plus were launched with
even more upgrades to the memory chipset
and camera and even the introduction of
3d touch however apple ran into its
first major manufacturing controversy
with these bigger models users were
finding that their iphones would easily
bend in their pockets and in some cases
it would lead to extensive damage the
controversy was called bendgate and it
led to apple recalling a huge number of
iphone 6 and 6 plus models after the
bengate controversy a serious analysis
of the entire manufacturing process was
undertaken by apple this led to a lot of
structural redesign of the iphones based
on how users use them on a day-to-day
basis as a result the new iphone 6s and
6s plus were manufactured out of a 7000
series aluminum sheet to make sure that
structural integrity is never
compromised again however this
controversy did little to impact
iphone's popularity over 2016 and 17
apple launched the iphone se series 7
and series 8. these models continuously
improved on iphone's construction
internal specs display quality camera
performance and ios features however the
most noticeable feature or the lack of
it was the removal of the headphone jack
from the iphone 7 and 7 plus in 2016.
the level of foresight that had
characterized the iphone's enormous
success worldwide was at play yet again
by the time the iphone x was released at
the end of 2017 exactly 10 years since
the first iphone users were already
getting used to not having a headphone
jack and began adapting to the wireless
lifestyle true wireless stereo or tws
headphones introduced with the iphone 7
and 8 the apple air pods were the new
game in town the world over and wired
music listening became less popular
iphone x and later the iphone xs and xs
mex models in 2018 removed the home
button for the first time and introduced
face id this led to an edge-to-edge
display and with the super retina hd
technology these newer phones attained a
whole nother level of gpu performance
like never before the next update came
in the form of the iphone 11 pro in 2019
this series of iphone established
apple's iphone as a true champion in the
field of mobile photography it featured
not two but three 12 megapixel hdr
camera lenses offering wide ultra wide
and telephoto lenses the camera system
would be further upgraded in the iphone
12 pro in 2020 with lidar scanning
improved night mode and enhanced zoom
range and lens functions iphone 12 pro's
cameras had the fastest aperture ever
used in an iphone apple also added raw
photos for superior pro editing
capability and improved their portrait
mode with advanced bokeh and depth
control the video recording software
side of things had also caught up with
the massive improvement in mobile camera
technology users can now record hdr
video with dolby vision up to 4k at 30
frames per second the new models also
introduced a wide range of advanced
cinematic features that are usually
found in very expensive cameras such as
continuous autofocus video stabilization
auto zoom slo-mo at 240 frames per
second night mode time lapse and many
more all this brings us to the present
and the latest line of iphones the
iphone 13 iphone 13 mini iphone 13 pro
and the pro max all launched in
september 2021. this new series of
iphones features apple's most powerful
chipset the a15 bionic and comes with up
to one terabyte internal storage the
battery life has also significantly
improved and is now able to support over
28 hours of continuous video playback
the end of 2022 will again see the
launch of newer iphone models as the
saga of the world's most popular
smartphone continues and we've discussed
this in our video on the iphone 14 in
just over 13 years phones have
transformed beyond anyone's imagination
as technological improvements have come
thick and fast this is also reflected in
the company's iphone launch cycles in
the early years apple launched one model
of iphone per year it then increased to
two a year with the introduction of
series five 2017 18 and 19 each saw the
release of three more iphone models 2020
saw the launch of five new models and
2021 saw the company roll out four
iphones in its series 13 lineup what
kind of upgrades are you hoping to see
in the next line of iphone models
subscribe to our channel and hit the
notification bell for more videos like
this see you in the next video